you didn't confuse get disconnected Mara
Simpson has found to redouble
anti-terrorist efforts Benjamin Walker
also known as the voice of freedom is a
known terrorist figure who recently
slipped through our borders Walker's a
spark people follow him we got to get
him back you are gonna tell me where I
can find Benjamin Walker then I'll teach
you how we operate just scream as loud
as you want okay out there she's the
best in the business I'm just trying not
to piss her off I'm Crawford
collaborator oh I've been resistance
from the very beginning this is the
vision the KPA sold us when they arrived
cooperation to rebuild America profit
sent a message the KPA know about the
armory they're gonna attack
sounds like examples time
this ain't no time for words anymore
more prayers or hope this is a time for
action this is the booth that's gonna
kick the KPA zas sounds like someone
needs a demonstration
I take my hand like this nor she got us
backed into a corner I
and
son of a [ __ ] and you're looking for
someone someone to tell you what to do
someone had to show your way out this is
a message for the terrorist group call
yourselves the resistance
all with chance I like water but is all
this rich water for one man
your little revolution a keiki is
stronger than you it's you want out of
this
have the foil around
don't let me down
you